all right look at all these questions
from people who gets the first question
you do do you agree with Elizabeth
Warren's plan to get rid of the Senate
filibuster
yeah there's certain circumstances yeah
if it were if the decisions between
every American gets health care or we
stick to this 60 vote rule then yeah
it's it's a crazy rule to begin with
right because it always was meant to be
simple majority and it just sort of
became this different to slow things
down I mean the Senate is meant to be
the body that is more deliberative as
hard as that is now to believe more
deliberative and the founders envisioned
that a state that this would slow things
down but it had but they never used to
use a dreg or for every single issue
right absolutely not I mean we used to
be able to trust each other little there
was an honor system but you could build
a consensus now you can't write a census
it's absolutely foreboding to vote with
anybody on the other side on anything we
can't use the honor system because I
answered for you one side is if people
know going into an election right that
you're going by majority rules 50 vote
50 or the vice president breaks a tie
that also clarifies to the electorate
where they're gonna be right so I think
we're moving in that direction okay will
Britain ever brexit gracefully now
what's the deal now they've moved up the
date that would I don't know that they
want to the European Union may not let
them know nobody knows I was in London
last week you would turn on the main
evening news and these very senior
newscasters would say you know I know
I'm supposed to tell you how this is
going to work out but I don't have a
clue yeah you know nobody knows from
minute to minute what's happening so
grace grace gracefulness is at the
window briggsie knows like the
Republicans original Obamacare health
care plan it was get rid of Obamacare
and then we'll see what happens next
they got rid of British foreign policy
British strategy and then said okay
let's figure out what happens next
nobody had any replacement plan and then
it turns out that all policies have
downsides and G being in Europe wasn't
that such a big
being compared to being out and now
having voted to get out but not knowing
where they go they don't know what to
donate and by the way just on the
subject of the simple majority of a that
referendum with a simple majority is
what has got us into this mess you know
that this is David Cameron's mess that
he called the referendum and said a
one-vote majority would be enough you
know that their vote to leave don't vote
it also reveals the other big problem
which is what you said which is that we
all know what we hate we just don't know
what we want but it's a failure of the
British ruling class and this is a cross
left to right you know Jeremy Corbyn is
not top of the list but he's quite close
to the top if Jeremy Corbyn had been
calling for a second referendum several
months ago it would have happened you
know but he's not really a European he
comes from that old trotskyist left
yeah he's correct which which thinks
that Europe is a rich man's club and we
shouldn't be in it you know he's not
gonna fight for Europe because he's
never been a European right you know so
so uhand that's a lot of what the but
the people who voted to leave feel like
they feel like we are this island this
emerald whatever that britain great
again
yeah but but what they forget is the
reason foreign islands britain's
greatness was exploiting the health of
1/4 of the world yeah of course yeah
right injured indian politician came to
Britain last year and made a speech in
which he said look when the British came
to India it was just about the richest
country in the world when the British
left India it was one of the poorest
where do you think the money with India
was one of the richest countries in the
world yeah yeah India at the end of the
bull Empire was unbelievably affluent
and the Bulls were colossally wealthy
and moguls were stock recei with lovely
titles and big crowd this was a country
which was raped as was a lot of Africa
sure etcetera and the kind of and the
kind of glorious moment of Britain's
England's precedents was based on that
yeah rape of the world right you know
now gee we don't want immigrants but we
went to their countries and [ __ ] them
over I think you do a little bit of a
disc
[Applause]
world war two was not an England what if
they would have just kissed the world on
the back of the head would that still be
I'm reading the question after the last
couple of weeks we've had are you still
attracted to robert muller i know you
said that you were sexually attracted to
robert muller I feel this way I love him
I like that kind of operation crossing
your T's dotting your eyes apparently
didn't cross all his T's well actually
William bar didn't cross all the t's but
I am waiting for the full report to
decide whether I want to pursue a sexual
really yes you should definitely wait
for the full report okay what are the
what are your takeaways panel from the
massive New York Times piece on the
Murdoch family and their global
political influence yeah they are they
are yes the whole family I they are the
secret to a lot of things because if
they would turn on the bass well if if
Fox News would stop becoming state media
as opposed to CNN and MSNBC you know
come on come on come on come on let's
all come here that is that is a false
analogy you know it's actually a totally
correct analogy no it's not Fox News is
pecans use of the right and the others
of what Fox News does not report a bad
year that has fact checkers yes sorry
sorry dude that's not a thing it doesn't
have fact checkers no I think CNN has
drifted to become the analog of Fox on
the other but bill was about to elect
Trump gave Trump the most amazing amount
of air turn also I mean and what do you
think their agenda was in so doing well
it certainly wasn't left-wing you can't
tear agenda agenda it's about what the
policies are if you can save things that
aren't true then it's okay and that's
one thing if you can sit in other places
you can say things that are not true and
you get recalled on it you know what
that I did know sorry
[Applause]
accountability that CNN and MSNBC have
that Fox does not have they'd apologize
that accountability to to say I'm sorry
for a false reporting or anytime they
make a mistake they actually say if you
think Fox ever says sorry we got it
wrong I just don't watch any of them but
I've seen Fox and CNN and MSN say they
got it wrong Fox just last week
announced the Trump was burning aid to
three Mexican countries yes not the
worst offense is that they don't report
things as if they didn't happened
reporting is the thing of the past
you just spent you just spent ten
minutes talking about how the media was
doing a bad job that is exactly the
theme that we keep that job is different
than not reporting at all when when
Trump said we have defeated Isis the
next day there was an Isis attack and it
killed Americans Fox did not report it
that's different that does not happen on
the other network okay
I think it's important to distinguish
evening Fox from daytime Fox I agree
with why what's the difference are they
nicer in the daytime there's an
editorial there are people at Fox who
are serious journalists doing serious
news and they're not necessarily the
news hosts at the Wallace or Bret Baier
or Shep people vote with their eyes
people do actually watch that just as
they're watching on msn well I mean I
think this is one reason then they'd be
recife ariz on top of it all sorry I
know I was as you said I think that
that's why the issue is not the
Murdoch's alone because if they went
away tomorrow they have set a blueprint
for how to do this that I think somebody
else would take up yes you're right
because the problem is us our
politicians our media people they're
responding to our preferences our tastes
our dollars we want this we are as a
society are choosing to go into this
because we like the fighting we like
watching politics as high sake if we
were to be mindful like Chelsea was
talking about there wouldn't be a market
for this they're just supplying what we
want yeah I mean you're gonna have to
face that out because they're also you
know I mean they're also I think
creating some of that right because they
they give that and it just resize it
like potato chips they give us more
things that we like them can't stop
eating them so what are your top three
issues what do you think the top three
issues the United States needs to focus
on
well I'm healthcare number one yeah I
would say it's number one secondly to me
is education I would say immigration
then climate change my first executive
order is no that's for oh I'll break the
rules what my first executive order
would be to recommit to the Paris
climate agreement on the first day
we wish you luck we wish everybody luck
I know it was a tough night for you with
everybody ganging up against you you
held up really well yes I know I
appreciate you doing it alright thank
you everybody
[Applause]
you